Вона стала справжнім символом Різдва.
Вона лунала у стінах кращих
концертних залів світу!
Це — популярна різдвяна композиція
«Carol of the Bells».
Пісня без якої Різдво — не Різдво.
Всього чотири ноти,
які об’єднали світ від північного
до південного полюсів,
від Аляски й до Австралії,
і які чула чи не кожна людина у світі.
Та далеко не всі знають,
що хоч слова пісні й написав популярний
американський диригент Пітер Вільговський,
музику до неї склав композитор український —
геніальний Микола Леонтович.
А в основі цього шедевру —
прадавня українська новорічна щедрівка.
♪  Щедрик-щедрик-щедрівочка
прилетіла ластівочка. ♪
Століття тому саме з приходом весни
для українців наставав Новий рік.
А провіщав його приліт ластівки,
який і оспівується у щедрівці.
За сто років українська пісня
розійшлася світом,
та стала неофіційним гімном Різдва.
Але перш ніж це сталося,
«Щедрик» пройшов довгий шлях,
ставши символом української боротьби
за незалежність від Росії.
Щойно завершилася Перша світова війна.
На Паризькій мирній конференції
держави-переможці установлювали
новий світовий порядок.
Американський президент Вудро Вільсон
у своїх знаменитих 14 пунктах
стверджував невід'ємне право народів
на самовизначення.
На тлі цих епохальних заяв,
держави Балтії, Закавказзя, Польща, Чехія,
Фінляндія, Україна та інші держави
отримують підстави сподіватися
на справедливе післявоєнне вирішення
своїх національних прагнень.
Українська Народна Республіка,
що буквально повстала з попелу,
проголошує свою незалежність:
«Справдилася колишня давня мрія батьків Твоїх.
Однині Українська Народна Республіка
стає самостійною, ні від кого незалежною
Вільною Суверенною Державою
Українського Народу».
Втім ентузіазм українців
не поспішали розділити
великі держави Європи та Америки.
Цим скористалася  відпрацьована століттями
російська пропагандистська машина,
яка щосили намагалася переконати світ,
що України не існує.
І поки політичні нащадки Леніна
не дійшли висновку,
що Україну придумав він,
тодішні російські міністри стверджували,
що  вигадав її Австрійський штаб.
Не бажаючи визнавати незалежність України,
більшовицька Росія розпочинає
повномасштабне вторгнення в Україну.
Захоплює не лише український схід,
а й саму столицю — Київ.
У переддень окупації голова УНР
Симон Петлюра
відправляє до Європи хор.
Як і в наші дні, не маючи достатніх засобів
до ведення війни,
Україна розуміла, що єдиний шанс вижити —
це виграти війну інформаційну,
та мобілізувати країни Європи
на підтримку України.
Тож Петлюра, розуміючи всі загрози,
почав шукати спосіб, як нагадати світові,
що Україна, по-перше, давно існує,
по-друге — окремо від Росії.
Широкий загал не знає, але випадок,
коли український президент
приходить із культурної сфери,
не ноу-хау України ХХІ століття.
Симон Петлюра, глава держави і
головнокомандувач української армії,
до війни  був публіцистом, журналістом,
арт-критиком та оглядачем театральних прем‘єр.
Тож було вирішено, що одним з напрямів
української культурної дипломатії
має стати найуніверсальніша з мов,
що здатна прорвати всі кордони — музика.
Симон Петлюра викликав до себе
композитора та диригента Олександра Кошиця
і наказав протягом тижня зібрати хорову капелу.
Для того, щоб знайти кращих хористів,
організували ледь не талант-шоу.
До репертуару, всупереч волі автора,
потрапляє й «Щедрик».
Чому всупереч?
Бо композитор Микола Леонтович
був аж надто до себе суворим.
Скромний учитель музики з Тульчина,
що на Поділлі,
неодноразово спалював свої партитури,
а над мелодією «Щедрика»
працював понад 10 років.
Втім, українська ластівочка
все ж полетіла світом.
Перший тріумфальний концерт
Української Республіканської Капели,
так назвали хор УНР,
відбувся 11 травня 1919 року
у столиці Чехословаччини.
Окрім «Щедрика» співали й
інші композиції Леонтовича,
а також твори Миколи Лисенка,
Кирила Стеценка, самого Олександра Кошиця.
Але всі слухачі: від Відня до Брюсселю,
від Барселони до Парижу,
були закохані у «Щедрика».
«Одна з найпрекрасніших пісень програми» –
писав лондонський журнал «Punch».
«Шедевр народного мистецтва» –
захоплювався колядкою
оглядач брюссельської газети «Le XX Sciècle».
Крапку ставили віденські ЗМІ:
«Культурна зрілість України має стати для світу
легітимізацією її політичної незалежності»
Стратегія Симона Петлюри спрацювала.
У наступні роки український хор збирає
у концертних залах королев,
президентів, міністрів, академіків, професорів.
Відвідує 10 країн,
дає більш ніж 200 концертів,
і викликає справжній бум.
«Щедрика» перекладають на іноземні мови,
в залах лунають вигуки: «Хай живе Україна!»
Понад півтисячі рецензій 10 різними мовами
про Україну та українську музику.
Ось результат європейських гастролей хору.
Сотні закордонних митців,
політиків та громадських діячів
надсилали на адресу хору листи з підтримкою
української культурної і політичної суб’єктності.
Тим часом на батьківщині «Щедрика»
події розгорталися трагічно.
Поки УНР вигравала війну
на культурному фронті,
військовий фронт,
що одночасно намагався стримати
багатотисячні війська і більшовиків,
і білих офіцерів,
які мріяли відновити Російську імперію,
все ж не витримав.
Попри очікування, військова допомога Україні
так і не була надана,
і на 70 років її було окуповано
совєтською Росією.
Почалися політичні репресії
і чистки незгідних з режимом –
так називали вбивства
української інтелігенції.
Під таку чистку потрапляє
і Симон Петлюра,
якого вбивають у Парижі просто на вулиці,
і Микола Леонтович –
1921 року митця вбив російський чекіст.
Його твори були оголошені неактуальними
для «совєтської доби»
і пам'ять про нього була стерта
на багато десятиліть.
Та «Щедрик» разом з хором Олександра Кошиця
продовжував жити.
1922 року він дістався західної півкулі.
І одразу до найпрестижнішої зали Нью-Йорка –
Карнегі Голл.
У цей же вечір американці вперше чують
мелодію свого майбутнього Різдвяного хіта.
Далі концерти у понад 100 інших
американських містах
Усюди «Щедрик» на біс.
Як і в Європі, колядка Леонтовича –
не лише хіт гастролей,
але й символ української боротьби
за незалежність.
«Співай, поневолена Україно!
Співай, щебетушко!
Прийде весна, якої ти чекаєш»  –
писав після прем’єри «Щедрика»
у Ріо-де-Жанейро
бразильський академік Енріке Коельо Нетто.
Утім чекати власної Весни
українцям доведеться довго.
Бо в Україні – «русская зима».
Кремлівська влада продовжує
нищити українську інтелігенцію,
мордувати голодом селян,
знищувати все,
що могло нагадати світові про Україну.
Втім, «Щедрик» про неї таки нагадує.
У 1936 році американський
композитор і диригент
українського походження
Пітер Вільговський
включає «Щедрик» до
репертуару свого шкільного хору
і презентує пісню на
найвідомішому радіо Америки NBC.
Після прем’єри,
музичні вчителі Америки завалюють
Вільговського проханнями
надіслати ноти «Щедрика».
У листопаді 1936 року
він публікує пісню у нью-йоркському
музичному виданні Карл Фішер.
І називає її «Carol of the Bells».
У партитурі зазначає:
це Українська Різдвяна Колядка;
музика – Миколи Леонтовича,
слова й аранжування – Пітера Вільговського.
Отак українська ластівка перетворюється
на американські дзвоники,
а «Щедрик» – на «Carol of the Bells».
Мелодія Миколи Леонтовича
стає різдвяним гімном США,
а згодом – усього світу.
Під цю мелодію грають у баскетбол,
знімають кіно, святкують Різдво,
та пиляють контент у TikTok.
В Англії «Щедрика» називають
«новорічною серенадою»,
в Латинській Америці —
«піснею великого чару»,
а в Канаді — «нововідкритим сфінксом».
Чому ж твір українського композитора
став настільки популярним?
Ця мелодія поза часом.
Вона існує між українським язичництвом,
яке черпало натхнення із самої природи
та американським Голлівудом.
Вона прикрасила кіносвіти
понад ста фільмів та серіалів,
серед яких такі хіти, як «Гаррі Поттер»,
«Міцний горішок» та невмирущі «Сімпсони».
От тільки про українське походження
цього шедевру,
як і про його надважливу культурну
й політичну місію,
знали навіть далеко не всі українці,
які вперше почули її в улюбленій
різдвяній комедії «Один вдома»,
що вийшла на екрани 1990 року.
Понад сторіччя «Щедрик» жив за океаном,
поєднуючи людей в їхній вірі у Різдвяне диво.
А через сто років ракета того ж
російського окупанта
прилетіла в київський будинок
на вулиці Олександра Кошиця.
Тільки цього разу світ вже не має сумнівів
щодо цієї суб’єктності,
здобутої в тому числі й українським «Щедриком»
сто років тому.
Закладені ще Симоном Петлюрою
основи для культурної дипломатії
дають свої плоди і зараз.
Українська пісня й культура
здобуває нові перемоги,
які посилюють та доповнюють інші:
дипломатичні та військові.
Аби врешті-решт українці відстояли свій дім,
та здобули головну перемогу.
Життя над смертю.
Свободи над рабством.
Слава Україні!
Героям слава!
Україна понад усе!